bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france un an plus tard
la chine semble être sorti d'affaires
quelle est la situation sanitaire dans
le pays aujourd'hui bien goûter elle se
porte on pourrait dire très bien puisque
après l'effort collectif de l'ensemble
du peuple chinois qui a fait corps avec
les autorités sanitaires aboutie du pays
on a pratiquement une stabilisation au
complète en chine et même un redémarrage
de l'économie
alors il faut être prudent parce que
nous savons qu'il ya des variantes du
virus qui peuvent encore circulé mais
les autorités de chinoise sans que
relativement je dirais optimiste par
rapport à la situation sanitaire du pays
je peux dire que incident relativement
peu de pays ont été finalement très rect
il faudrait pas mais l'essentiel c'est
que aujourd'hui nous tous au niveau
planétaire nous puissions lutter
efficacement contre la copie 19
mais quelle stratégie a été mise en
place en chine pourquoi est-ce-que
ailleurs dans le monde
visiblement ça ne fonctionne pas aussi
bien en fait je pense qu'il y ait eu une
défiance par rapport à la chine sur sa
politique sanitaire à savoir mener un
confinement qui est pour nous à l'époque
nous paraissait drastique à savoir faire
finalement ce que nous faisons nous
aujourd'hui avec des paniques mans des
mesures barrières mais dès le départ des
masques et puis des contrôles pour
savoir des personnes qui étaient
positives ou non et puis ensuite des
aménagements qui permettait aux
populations de ne pas affecter donc
c'est cette politique qui était
également dans des pays comme le vietnam
ou d'autres qui ont permis effectivement
l'éradication
mais c'est au prix effectivement d'un
effort collectif vraiment très important
parce qu'effectivement c'est toute la
population chinoise les les
j'étais unis pour lutter contre eux
contre le cool contre la collègue 19
pékin a récemment affirmé que le virus
proviendrait d'autres pays d'autres dans
le monde juge la chine responsable de la
pandémie et demande des réparations
comment est ce qu'on fait la part des
choses
où en sont aussi des enquêtes sanitaires
pour pour déterminer l'origine de la
pandémie
vous savez dans les débats qui sont
absolument philippe un virus n'a pas de
régime et des hymnes et quelque part sur
la planète il a muté il faut parfois des
dizaines des centaines d'années pour
pour n'être est un virus n'est pas plus
américains africains ou chinois ainsi
alizée que le vih et américains ou
africains non il faut être sérieux
effectivement oui il ya de fortes
présomptions mais finalement ce n'est
pas très important que le virus soit
paru auparavant ailleurs mais si vous
avez une idée essentielle aujourd'hui
c'est que l'ensemble des pistes du monde
luttent effectivement contre cette
pandémie et choix solidaire également
des pays en voie développement s'ils ont
peut-être deux voix aussi quand convient
de les aider dans cette lutte conjointe
quel impact finalement locaux vides 19
at il eu sur la chine au plan des
relations internationales notamment
alors que pékin a été les premiers mois
de la crise pointé du doigt pour sa
responsabilité présumée dans la pandémie
oui vous savez c'est un petit peu facile
de pointer du doigt pays mais quels
qu'ils soient
parce que un virus est apparu dont on
sait très bien que le villiériste de
lakovic 19 contrairement à ce qui était
dit par certaines autorités non
américain n'est pas d'origine humaine ne
pas être fabriquée donc je crois qu'il
ya une campagne de désinformation et je
dirais de complète sur ce sujet mais je
pense que nous passons aux états unis un
autre administration ce qui permettra
effectivement de d'avoir une vision d un
peu plus claire de ce qu'il vous êtes
notre destin c'est à dire une communauté
de destin partagé pour lutter contre les
effets nocifs du gier et duco vide
en aucun cas la chine est responsable du
comité qui s'en sort aussi
très bien économiquement vous le
rappeler il ya quelques instants oui bah
écoutez la chine a payé un lourd tribut
également mail appris comment le disait
très au sérieux dès le départ la
pandémie en tout cas ce qui était à
l'époque une épidémie ou un risque
pandémique
je pense que nous autres en occident
mais c'est aussi un but logique on est
pas obligé de croire dès le départ ce
qu'ils ont dit nous n'avons pas pris
suffisamment au sérieux ce que nous
disait le président chinois qui avertit
le msd qu'elle a su merci d'avoir pris
le temps de répondre à nos questions
pierre picard géopolitologue le
spécialiste de la chine